foreign
I do not suppose to know everything
and those closest to me they might say I
don't really know much at all but
one thing that I know to be true beyond
the shadow of a doubt is this
the surest way to fail in life
is to set a goal
now unfortunately I found this out
through excruciating pain but hopefully
in the next nine minutes I can convince
you too that this is true without the
pain unless of course you consider
listening to me painful okay
the year was 2011.
I was seeking to become a
multi-millionaire by the age of 21. so
how was I going to do this
it was simple
I was going to leave college at the
University of Texas
one year early I was going to leave
after my junior year and declare for the
National Football League draft in order
to do this however you have to submit
your resume to the NFL a resume in
football it is your your highlight tapes
from your Years playing prior so I
submitted my football tape for my
freshman my sophomore and my junior year
the NFL sent me back a letter
if simply read dear Emanuel you will not
be drafted in the first three rounds
excuse you
I won't be drafted in the first three
rounds so what did I do Ted audiences
simple I set a goal that day
but you know what they say about goal
setting you got to write it down commit
it to memory
so I highlighted the sheet of paper dear
Emanuel you won't be drafted in the
first three rounds and I put it above my
bed in my condo in Austin Texas every
morning I woke up I looked at it dear
manual you won't be drafted in the first
three rounds every night before I went
to sleep I looked at it dear Emanuel you
won't be drafted in the first three
rounds I worked tirelessly
my senior year in college with one goal
in mind
be drafted in the first three rounds of
the NFL draft those are the most
prestigious rounds after all 6 a.m
workouts in College Study Hall class I'm
doing it all with one goal in mind
well fast forward one year later I'm at
the NFL combine the NFL combine it is
the job interview I'm in front of 32
billionaires 32 of the richest men in
America if not the richest men in the
world they are the owners of every NFL
team
I'm running the 40-yard dash the 40-yard
dash is one of the testing metrics you
use at the NFL combine with millions of
dollars on the line the faster you run
the higher you get drafted
I take my mark
I proceed to run
I hear pop pop
I keep running I think my heels are
clicking pop pop pop
I clutch my quad I fall to the ground
it was my quad being torn off the bone
I ripped my quad off the bone I'm I'm
falling in ground in agony in front of
the 32 billionaires
I didn't get drafted in the first three
rounds of the NFL draft
I made a decision that day
in that moment
to stop setting goals my self-esteem
ruined self-efficacy ruined that last
year of my life seemingly gone to waste
because I had one goal y'all it was
simple be drafted in the first three
rounds then I tore my quad and it all
fell apart
what I failed to mention thus far is why
I tore my quad
two days prior at the NFL combine I
weighed in at 240 pounds in the NFL the
bigger you are the better but as you all
know wait it don't move all that fast so
I cut 10 pounds within two days I ran
the 40-yard dash two days later at 230
pounds dehydrated dieted for two days
why because I was so focused on my goal
that I caused harm to myself
it's not that goals don't add value it's
just that the risk of goal setting it is
greater than the potential reward think
about it in your own life for a moment
maybe you have the goal of being in a
relationship
so you ignore the toxic Behavior
think about it in your own life see one
of my greatest accomplishments to date
being an NFL player because ultimately I
did play for four years I view
negatively because I didn't hit my goal
maybe that's the same for some of you
maybe you have the goal of reading a
certain amount of books in a year you've
become a much more proficient reader but
you didn't hit your goal
maybe you had a goal of making a certain
amount of money for your business you
are a thriving entrepreneur but you
didn't hit
your goal
I left the NFL
I became a content creator where I would
live a much more Limitless life
I'll get to that more here in a moment
the question now is why in the world do
we set goals well first
let's define a goal
a goal by definition it is the end
towards which effort is aimed
but why would I start something
with the end in mind
and working on my master's degree in
sports psychology I focused on goal
setting I wrote my final thesis on it
and I realized we set goals for three
primary reasons the first
we've been indoctrinated with this
belief that we have to set a goal to
achieve there's a popularized study
which has since been debunked which said
the person who writes their goals down
and commits them to Memory they will
earn twice as much money as the person
who doesn't
so what you want me to believe
is the difference between one million
dollars and five hundred thousand
dollars is this
what you want me to believe is the
difference between a hundred thousand
dollars and fifty thousand dollars is
simply this
can't be now these ideas aren't
completely off base the problem is very
simple they're misidentifying causation
and correlation surely there is a
correlation between the person who's
willing to go the extra mile and write
their goal down
and the person who's willing to go the
extra mile in their business but no the
reason you're making twice as much money
is not because you wrote your goal down
the second reason we set goals
goals give us a North star motivation is
if we just be wandering around life
aimlessly if we didn't set a goal
the final reason we set goals
we have this insatiable desire for
feedback and feedback it is a
predecessor it's the necessary aspect of
goal setting think about it in your own
life did this Instagram post get as many
likes as that Instagram post did this
tweet get as many likes as my last tweet
how about this Tick Tock post did it get
as many shares as my last we have this
insatiable desire for feedback
you know I made a mistake earlier
I said the surest way to fail in life is
to set a goal
but no honesty
the only way to fail in life is to set a
goal think about anything you've ever
failed at maybe relationally
occupationally educationally that
marriage had ended in divorce you didn't
get into that college that you wanted to
you didn't pass the MCAT you didn't pass
the LSAT whatever the case may be it was
all Tethered to a goal it's not just
that the surest way to fail in life is
to set a goal the only way to fail in
life is to set a goal so what do I
suggest we do instead here it is
you have an objective with no
limitations now I know what you're
thinking Ocho that's semantics no the
small difference will have a huge impact
in your life objective effort aimed in a
direction a goal the end towards which
energy is aimed
your objective it should be subjective
it should be subject to people's
interpretation that way you do not fail
the theme of this conference is
possibilities
you all have spent money left your homes
maybe children because somewhere deep
down inside you you subscribe to this
notion of possibility
but you can't simultaneously subscribe
to the notion of possibility while still
being held captive by goal setting
the laws of goal setting completely
undermine the freedom of possibility
so if we're being honest with ourselves
we have to choose one because
possibility
is Limitless
but goal setting oh it's fixated on an
end
if you want to have a 10 million dollar
business you'll set that goal and you
might do just that have a 10 million
dollar business congratulations you'll
work towards a 10 million dollar
business but what if it could have been
more
if you want to run a mile without
stopping you'll work towards it and you
might do just that
having never known if you could have run
a marathon
what does it look like practically
Kirk Hammett lead guitars for Metallica
he never had the goal of winning eight
Grammys he never had the goal of selling
125 million records never had the goal
of being a rock star he simply said and
I quote
I just want to play my guitar a little
bit better every day
close quote see because with that there
is no end
a goal by its definition it is focused
on an ending which means inherently a
goal is limiting it's not that goals in
and of themselves have no value it's
just what about the damage you have done
to yourself your self-esteem your
self-efficacy the way in which you view
yourself when you look at yourself what
about that damage
I'm not saying don't achieve I'm saying
achieve limitlessly I'm saying believe
in the reason you were all sitting in
here today because you believe in
possibility let go of the Captivity of
goal setting and achieve all you
actually have to achieve
so what is my objective with no
limitations
very simply puts to be considered one of
the most creative people the television
industry has ever seen
because if I would have achieved my goal
of being drafted in the first three
rounds of the NFL draft
I never would have achieved this
winning a prime time Emmy Award and
sharing that moment with my mom
but just as importantly
if I would have achieved my goal of
being drafted in the first three rounds
of the NFL draft
I wouldn't be standing in front of you
all today why
because if you hear nothing else
truly if you hear nothing else
hear this
I'm begging each and every one of you to
the goal that you achieve
it's actually the penalty
that you receive
for having set that goal in the first
place thank you
thank you
foreign